[singing]
And as you guys can see, we're still in
the alleyway. The back alleyway hasn't
changed.
It's not necessarily suitable for
families but alhamdulillah we are you
know still continuing with the da you
know
and nobody knows those true soldiers of
Allah. Alhamdulillah donations are
coming through. It's helping us out
tremendously
and we implore you all out there to
carry on donating. Inshallah one day we
will have a masid
but like I said please don't forget us
in your duas and also to keep donating
we are more than happy to carry on with
the dawa but as you guys know with this
given situation
it's not the best of places to be by the
week just uh roll this camera around
this way just to get the people uh to
see what we're dealing with on a daily
basis.
>> Yeah. Here. Look, you know, these are
the sort of things we've got here.
And uh we come towards this way.
>> But basically, this is a good shot. So
when it really rains,
>> you know, severely, there's puddles
everywhere. So you can barely even walk
down this pathway here. You can barely
even walk because the puddles come up to
around here and you're having to like
literally jog from one spot to another
tiptoeing all the way. And as you can
see, this is not the ideal sort of place
for anybody to be. For men, it's not too
bad, but for families, children, for the
sisters,
come on. You know what I mean? There's
risks here. So, this is the situation
we're in. So, just come down this way.
As you can see, alhamdulillah, the
situation in terms of how it was
previously is getting a lot better. It's
getting a lot better in terms of the
pathway around it. But at times it's
really bad, you know, and that's the sad
part about it all. The situation of this
masid is not getting better. So we ask
obviously you know bless us with a place
to come but also don't forget our
situation you know and that your
donations they mean something to us and
on top of that it goes to a place where
we put it straight back into the
community in terms of dawa in terms of
teaching in terms of resources in terms
of the videos you see online.
[singing]
So, alhamdulillah, you know, that's the
best of things that you guys can
visually see online.
Yeah. Alhamdulillah
to my dear brothers and sisters.
Firstly, the messenger of Allah wasallam
said,
"If you're not grateful to your people,
you not be grateful to Allah." So, we
thank you and we appreciate your efforts
for helping the masjid with your with
your donations. May Allah bless you all.
And alhamdulillah, you really really
helped us. Alhamdulillah. And
alhamdulillah, you can see where your
money is going. Class here for free.
Alhamdulillah. Leaflets, books.
Alhamdulillah.
>> [singing]
>> So uh the masjid maintenance
alhamdulillah is still running mashallah
you know we have the the im caretaker
alhamdulillah and of course we still
looking we are still looking for a
bigger place which is we need to make
sincere dua to Allah to give us one in
she's bush because you know we don't
want to go out we want to be in bush
while we stand and of course it's very
Bush is very expensive and also is very
hard to find a place for masjid or place
of worship. So again may Allah bless all
my dear brothers and sisters. We ask
Allahh to bless you and bless your
wealth and bless your health and bless
your families
and whatever you can help and continue
to donate. Then do not believe to
nothing as said do not believe to
nothing. Even if you given half of date
for the sake of Allah, even meeting your
brother with a smiling smiley face. May
Allah bless you all.
[singing]
>> [singing]